the only two games they lost were
without curry where they lost to Denver
and Charlotte here at home there's
Williams from the corner of three just
clink faster than everybody else
the Warriors travel Milwaukee tomorrow
for a Friday night game on ESPN also and
Korea's day-to-day so fortunately for
the team this won't keep them out very
long could be a free agent can opt out
in the summer but were signed Blake
Griffin in the summer to that sig
extension as Lou Williams hits Anna
Griffin missed 15 games rockets in
Phoenix Friday at ESPN and I'll say this
just mention Williams hits a three then
a very good job he's 16 and 23 tips over
the team after all Watson as fire three
games in the season Lou Williams again
like that I come up with stuff to go
enjoy I know that you criticized a
play-by-play guys a lobster just going
snaps out Williams for three but 12
boards now leads the league in
rebounding flippers hanging in there
midway through the third down six here's
Williams on the drive scoops and scores
to make other warriors be the shooters
Lou Williams ties the game at 81 he's
got 24 points Williams off the Jordans
screen with a pull up Jay yes
Williams 26 on the night why it's Witten
the compote going for the rebound Jordan
back to Williams putts it and 28 for Lou
Williams 15 here in the court lays made
its last six shots Williams for three
buries it swishes at home 31 for
Williams just get started to loose ball
picked up by Wallace here's Williams 21
in the third quarter 34 on the night
ginger here in the third quarter about a
three-second difference between the game
and shot clocks Lou Williams being
double-teamed shoots overcasting pets
Lou Williams with 26 in the quarter goes
by any player in any quarter in the NBA
this year 40 points for the game and
he's got to put it up here with one on
the timer and he puts it through
wouldn't the young man in high school
rather be playing with his friends as
you know this long long three or 47 a
bus ride the sacrament that won't be a
pleasant one thirty seconds ago Lou says
why not
his first 50-point yeah it is